hey guys hey everybody welcome back to
the Samsung stage
I'm your host camera all that said and
I'm joined by Dave Weber David would you
prefer if David French there we go away
back and Dave we're gonna talk about
evil within but yes we do that how was
your read three going how are you doing
oh really well yeah having a great time
we got hands on over to booth so I'm
getting to watch a bunch of people be
scared out of their minds which is
always exciting anyone like shrieked
really all three Tyson shrieks yeah yeah
in tears no tears had a bit of
tomfoolery
so maybe actually we should get Chris
waters and whenever gates po-hos he's
terrible with horror games oh yeah so
we're gonna we should definitely try and
send him over awesome I'd love to see
them yeah so em let's let's actually
talk about the game and what the build
you're showing off here sure at e3 so uh
I think we've got some some gameplay to
show as well so yes or than up on screen
for you guys at home but just talk me
through what's what wasn't you are you
showing off so we're showing off two
sections of the game one of them is
pretty far through chapter a and one of
them is from Chapter four one of them is
more puzzle based showing how you have
to unravel the level to sort of progress
and find out the backstory of what's
actually happened to you and one of them
is uh focused a little bit more on pure
horror but what we're seeing on screen
right now why'd he sit in that chair
yeah so the terrible idea that's the
Upgrade chair there so you're getting a
little bit a little look at how the
character upgrades throughout the game
pretty gruesome yeah so you collect this
this stuff called green shell and then
you get to put it towards your
attributes like your stamina your
ability to run away into your head yeah
so even the upgrading is a painful
process yeah but this area that you're
in right now where the upgrades are
located and where it'll save your game
is this Asylum that where the game
starts but you're not really sure
whether or not this Asylum is the real
world or if the levels that you sort of
transition into with the real world so
you can see here Sebastian Castellanos
who's the detective the main character
of the game is now walking towards a
mirror at the far end of this asylum and
when he gets closer he'll sort of lose
consciousness and transition into the
level proper and you never really know
whether or not he's going into reality
or whether he was in reality so it's
part of the psychological horror guys
that kind of what's real what's know all
the way through the game yeah exactly a
lot of these levels will shift
change around you it it's meant to keep
you on your toes you don't really know
what's happening or why and you're
trying to unravel how you got into this
situation so this level what we're
watching right now is is a mansion a
mansion level and this plays into the
backstory of the game you're trying to
find out who this nemesis is in the game
called Rubik who's been pursuing you
throughout the entire experience so you
originally go in to the mansion
following two characters who are in a
horrific car crash with you you're just
trying to catch up to them and now
you're locked into this moment from
Rubik past and you're trying to find out
what his motivations are for putting you
into this terrible situation realist
intentions yeah so people are able to
play this at the show and and the other
section like I said a little bit more
pure survival horror where there's
there's a little bit more combat so what
you're gonna see here is Sebastian's
able to UM to sneak so stealth is
actually really important in this game
it allows you to conserve ammo and
anybody who's played a game created by
Makani son before knows that the pushing
pool of resources is really important
especially in survival horror so anyway
that you can conserve every bullet
you're gonna want to try to do that so
sneaking went wrong yeah so who are
these guys
can we see what these guys are yeah so
these are called the haunted they're
definitely not alive they are they are
undead and ammo doesn't really always
work with them too well so a number of
bullets might not take them down you'll
have to find other ways like for example
right here there's a proximity mind on
the wall there and and what we did is
waited for one of the haunted to walk
towards it and then set it off at the
last moment to take him out that made
pretty pretty quick work of in this game
made good work of them so the push and
pull of resources plays into a lot of
parts of this game but what you're
seeing right now is the character ruvik
this this main nemesis in the game will
appear throughout this level and pursue
you there's absolutely no way for you to
harm this character so your best bet now
is just to run and if he catches up to
you you're a goner
oh really game over if he gets you it's
game over if he gets towards you and and
even if you turn around
fire Adam we're showing it here a little
bit for dramatic effect but if you shoot
at him he'll then teleport closer to you
if you land a hit and you'll die even
faster so there's many many moments in
this game where your only option is to
turn tail and try to escape these look
he's not constrained by normal physics
so these are not at all and get that
classic horror movie vibe where there's
this unstoppable force coming at you
there's nothing you can do but you're
good yeah so you can see what happened
there is you know you have to run away
from him but he pushed us right into
another confrontation okay that's like a
spear in his face or something that's
that's that can't be good
that can't be good so right there
there's an example of lighting the
enemies on fire all right so you may not
take a guy out with bullets you do have
another another option which are matches
matches are a limited resource as well
so you can use those to conserve ammo
and something else that's that's pretty
interesting is the health packs the full
health packs that that give you the most
amount of health back to your character
also have this effect that severely
distort your field of view and you can
see why that might be a problem right
here oh wow
so yeah nothing is really a things
really for free in this game is it
nothing's for free nothing safe and you
really have to think through how you're
gonna purchase X approaching section
because all of the health that he got
back he then lost because he was
attacked during that that lost the field
of view so you were saying you know you
mentioned you had a few people at your
booth you know yelping and screeching
the way through this demo so what's your
what's your approach to your kind of
ethos to creating horror and evil within
you know cuz like there's a bunch of you
know horror genres growing you know it's
be some great examples of horror games
that have you know famously really hit
home with people like slender was you
know really popular and yeah and they're
like what's you know some people go for
jump scares some people go for other
stuff like what's this so so that
section is great what you're trying to
do there in a very short amount of time
is hit that top light to stop being
pulled toward the grinder so you have a
very limited amount of time to get
yourself out of that trap but I think
really the ethos behind evil within is
if you've ever played a game from a
commie son you know that it's it's
really all about balance it's
about management of resources and this
building tension so I think the game is
sort of best described by the scenario
where you go into an area you have three
enemies and two bullets and now you need
to figure out how you're gonna get get
through and there are a lot of options
open to you but they're all based around
this overbearing tension of how do you
solve that problem and and once you get
past that section what's going to be
just around the corner so you may go
forage for more resources to tackle that
issue but in in looking for those
resources you're gonna encounter
something just as awful so you have this
tension building throughout the game as
you're trying to advance and solve solve
this puzzle and solve the mystery of why
you're in this situation what happened
to you so you trying to kind of
constantly add to that that sense of
foreboding exactly oh this this building
dread yes that's quite interesting cuz
em I mean I I do have some people my
what they have so many guys been
watching my Noah I do a show for games
but all about science of video games and
then a show I was telling you earlier
about like how you create horror in
terms of science and what people
actually respond better to you know jump
scares can give you that quick kind of
thrill but it is that like building
sense that is more terrifying like
knowing that you're about to get minced
by something that's actually far more
terrifying or or if you see you walk
along the corridor and you see blood and
then you see more and more little parts
hinting at that doom that's just coming
up that is far more terrifying generally
for most people and I think that's a
really good way to describe this game I
mean there are those punchy jump scares
you know throughout this experience but
what are you yeah but what it's really
about is this this building tension
throughout the entire experience where
the more you learn the more you know
that danger is around every corner and
you have a set of options to how you're
gonna approach that danger but none of
them are gonna be safe all of them are
gonna be difficult and all of them are
gonna be no terrifying so yeah so I'll
meet you guys so you know when you were
like okay we want to want to make a
horror game what made you go
third-person you know like I suppose the
first person that was completely up to
at Mikami son and I think he has a great
history with with that type of game and
for him this was really a return to form
you know an opportunity to go back to
the genre that he really founded he's
like you know the grandfather of
survival horror and this this is sort of
his ultimate
vision of survival or fantastic so I'm
when can we expect to when can we expect
to see more it's more of the evil within
yeah so after III we're just gonna keep
showing off the game until its release
on October 21st you will see a little
bit more coming up pretty soon but I
invite everybody to stay tuned we got
some more stuff and if you are at e3 you
can you can check it out you can have a
hands on we have we have hands on at the
booth the c3 which is really great
that's really exciting to see people
finally play the game it's really the
only real way to experience survival
horror you got to get your hands on it
you know the tension that I was
describing is only conveyed through
experiencing it in the game you know
knowing that you have these limited
resources knowing that you could be
taken out at any time you know you have
to play it to really get it fantastic
yeah I mean I think that's definitely
with survival horror Ryan's really you
experiencing it yeah anyway because it
is about whether or not it it grips you
and whether or not it scares you
basically speaking of actually have you
have you seen you got to see any of the
other kind of horror games on the show I
was hearing really good things about the
they can oculus enabled demo of alien
isolation have you had to I basically I
was only allowed to leave my booth for
this interview so thank you very much
welcome you got at run I have been I
have been playing the evil within
straight through so afterwards I got a
chance to take a look at everything at
e3 but until then yeah well then you're
gonna be tied to the boot it's been a
real pleasure talking to you now if
anyone at home actually has a question
for David the best way to ask him would
be right now to give me a tweet in the
next like minute to act cam frass Rob I
will fill up on this and I will ask
David directly but tell me just tell me
a bit more about about them I'm really
interested in that upgrades yeah you
show us earlier we only saw briefly and
I know that's new right that's a new
thing you showed up so what other type
of things can you what kind of abilities
can you upgrade to kind of shape your
character as you go well I think one of
the one of the more important ones I
mean you can upgrade a lot of abilities
weapon accuracy individual to each
weapon your agony crossbow which is sort
of like your weapon of last resort
that's actually an interesting one to
talk about because in the game there are
these traps like proximity mines or
tripwires and they result in horrific
death but if you're careful if you sneak
towards these and you're
aware of them you can then disassemble
the traps and take the parts then once
you have those parts you can turn them
into crossbow bolts which are very rare
in the world and definitely your most
powerful weapon okay and also a weapon
of distraction there's one that blinds
enemies so that you can stagger them or
maybe just run away so then you're able
to upgrade the crossbow bolts and the
crossbow itself all of these weapons you
know what they do is they give you a
better chance at survival
none of them are are sure thing none of
them are overpowered to the point where
you feel like you can take on anything
in this world and like I said before
there's a lot of there's a lot of
enemies in the evil within that you
cannot be you have to turn tail and run
from which is part of that tension you
have to feel like you're in danger and
and that's the goal of this game you are
definitely in danger at the demo today
we have a couple of encounters where if
you try to stand your ground you're just
not gonna make it well I should got a
couple good questions coming through
from Twitter for the moment so let's go
to that so add we have Regina Perez says
how long did it take to come up with
designs for the monsters in the evil
within oh that's a great question for
one of our concept artists I I have to
speak to her directly to get the answer
for that but the designs you know that
the art for these these monsters are are
terrifying when inspiration come from I
hope it's not like things they've
imagined because that's pretty messed up
yes Nakamura son is a brilliant artist
and that's that's a great question I
don't really feel comfortable speaking
for her about but yeah I would love to
show off some of the original character
art and some of the concept art and we
have that we're gonna be showing it off
as well to our community but all of its
amazing tastic are we Mosca another
question from Sam wood and Sam asks will
there be a currency in the game will
there be a currency in the game I guess
is he mean in terms of upgrades yeah you
were talking so that's the green jello I
was talking about where you get this gel
is sometimes after you kill an enemy
it's left behind when their bodies
dissolve and also you can find it in
these large mason jars when exploring so
that's the closest thing to currency and
what you do is you then accumulate that
and then take it to the upgrade room and
use it to spend on something like
stamina or a little bit of increased
health all right I'm just gonna keep
throwing these out you've got some great
questions right so we got Alex now
saying hey a cow France Ralph does the
evil within take inspiration from older
movies similar to Donnie Darko
that's what yes but you know I think you
see a little bit of a little bit of
horror from a lot of sources it sort of
runs the gambit of really great classic
horror movies and I think you can get
that feel a little bit when you see the
design of it you get this like very
classic horror vibe just from the sort
of the the lighting and the setting of
the game I've definitely had that
experience playing it myself where I
feel like I'm back I'm like reliving
some of my favorite classic horror
experiences fantastic well Dave Dave I'm
gonna call you Dave again it's been a
pleasure having you on stage time for
the wall but thanks for bringing on and
bring along that demo of you move in
it's been great to see it's great to
have it here at e3 also some good horror
and so yeah go off and enjoy the rest of
the show thank you guys watching home do
you not go anywhere I keep saying that
it's the corny line but it's true cuz we
got loads more games we still got
another what time is I have know what
time it is it's someone's 3 o'clock we
still got like two more hours or
something crazy on this stage so don't
go anywhere
we'll be back in just a few minutes with
you yet another demo